et
les images d'actualités égyptienne
montrant l'hystérie générale
l'explosion de haine dirigée contre le
minuscule état d'israël
des armes et missiles soviétiques offert
aux égyptiens par leurs alliés ruche des
cadeaux de prix
l'entraînement intensif des troupes
d'élite égyptienne juste avant la guerre
israélo arabe des six jours en 1967
une bien meilleure performance devant la
caméra que celle qui suivra sur le champ
de bataille
juste avant la guerre lorsqu on posera
aux chefs des forces de libération de la
palestine la question des éventuels
réfugiés israëlien celui ci répondra pas
de problème puisqu'il ne restera aucun
juif
autre époque autre pays
et pourtant de frappante ressemblance la
montée active et menaçante du mouvement
national socialiste en allemagne au
début des années 30
hitler le grand démagogue galvanise les
foules en utilisant la technique
ancestrale du bouc émissaire pour
justifier les défaites passées et les
difficultés du pays
au début on ne le prend pas au sérieux
son jeune chef de la propagande joseph
goebbels est considéré comme une figure
comique on brûle les livres un acte
barbare qui fait grincer le monde
civilisé mais qui ne suscite aucune
riposte
hitler est le premier dictateur à
mesurer toute l'importance des mass
media il fait diffuser par sa propagande
le fameux protocole des sages de sion
info un vulgaire tracts antisémites
suivi par des lois interdisant aux juifs
l'exercice de certaines professions et
ce n'est que le début d'une longue liste
d'actions visant à humilier et détruire
les citoyens juifs allemands la nuit les
chemises brunes des sections d'assaut
nazis entre de force chez les opposants
politiques
les traînent dans la rue et les fonds
des filets pour les ridiculiser aux yeux
du public
déjà au début du siècle un tyran d'une
autre ère le tsar nicolas avait instauré
des lois encourageant la population à se
dresser contre les juifs
une fois de plus bouc émissaire
un sanglant déchaînement qui s'est
fréquemment répété au fil des siècles
au coeur du désert arabe la terre de la
bible l'ancestrale patrie des hébreux
abandonné négligé depuis des siècles
sous la domination despotique et cruelle
des turcs qu'un cri lointain venant du
pays où coulent le lait et le miel
pourtant dans l'esprit le coeur et les
prières de tous les juifs depuis 2000
ans d'exil subsiste le rêve messianique
du retour dans cette région plusieurs
civilisations prospérer pour s'évanouir
en poussière de tous les peuples
antiques
seuls les juifs ont réussi à survivre en
1897 theodor herzl penseur politique
juif relance l'idée d'un état juif
moderne sur la terre biblique de
palestine de jeunes intellectuels de
russie partage son rêve de retour une
ville entièrement juive tel aviv est
fondée sur les dunes de sable en 1909
ben gourion le jeune homme aux poings
serrés photographier avec un groupe de
pionniers
quelques membres de la légion juive au
cours de la première guerre mondiale
cette guerre qui a mobilisé des millions
de soldats dans quantité de nation
provoque misère et souffrance
l'europe en ruine les masses de soldats
et de civils rentrer chez eux les juifs
comme les autres ont perdu des jeunes
gens qui repose dans des cimetières
militaires ont erré trangères après la
guerre lord balfour secrétaire d'état
britannique aux affaires étrangères
déclare que le gouvernement de sa
majesté envisage favorablement
l'établissement palestine d'un foyer
national pour le peuple juif le pays
passe alors sous le contrôle de
l'angleterre et la société des nations
le déclare sous mandat britannique
jerusalem l'antique mur des lamentations
une partie du second et dernier temple
hébreu lieu saint pour les juifs du
monde entier
dès lors pour beaucoup le travail
remplace les prières un dur labeur pour
racheter la terre l'activité physique
succède à la banque et au commerce
planter des arbres au labour et le sol
regarder avec fierté pousser les
semences reconstruire israël en
cultivant sa terre à la sueur du front
et avec l'amour du travail
la tour de david et les vestiges de
l'ancienne jérusalem sites favoris des
visiteurs du monde entier
vêtu à l'occidentale ou arborant le fais
musulmans turcs les juifs cohabite avec
l'en voisins arabes
les touristes se mêlent à la population
locale où s'abritent à l'ombre dans la
chaleur des rues
les vieux continue de prier au mur des
lamentations ce lieu où les pierres
raconte 2000 ans d'histoire
et les jeunes poursuivent la
construction de la nouvelle jérusalem
scènes de rues de l'époque des édifices
publics d'inspiration orientale
automobile se mêlant aux carrioles
tirées par les chevaux l'industrie du
bâtiment naissante des méthodes très
primitive selon les critères
d'aujourd'hui et qui permettent de mener
le travail a bien quel que soit le temps
qu'il faudra
les chameaux au mauvais caractère
antipathique et maladroit mais tellement
utile
e
deux jeunes pionniers déterminés à bâtir
une idée nouvelle
dans un vieux pays
ailleurs les marécages infestés par la
malaria et qu'il faut dégager
on creuse des tranchées pour acheminer
l'eau vers les lieux de culture des
kilomètres de canalisations qui
alimenteront des étendues désertes
l'eau tellement vitale pour faire
fleurir un sol aride dans un pays créé
au milieu du désert depuis la nuit des
temps la recherche et l'exploitation de
l'eau ont été la clé permettant de
rendre la terre productive et de créer
de nouvelles implantations
voici comment se créer l'une d'entre
elles dans les années 30
le groupe quitte ses tentes pour établir
sa communauté
les britanniques limite les permis de
construire mais selon la loi turque
si le toit d'un bâtiment est monté avant
l'aube on ne peut le détruire
alors tôt le matin les en charge dans
des camions le matériel nécessaires à
l'érection de leur propre villa
et on emporte aussi des fils barbelés
essentiel pour se défendre contre la
menace des bandits arabe
les fusils accompagne les travailleurs
au chant à l'image des premiers
pionniers américains
le bâtiment le plus important est le
premier à être érigés c'est la tour de
get
on dresse les pans de murs préfabriqués
puis la toiture pour les futurs
occupants et enfin les connexions
électriques matthieu zem la maison de
joseph de jeunes pionniers créant leur
propre communauté pour fonder une
famille dans l'espoir de mener une
existence paisible et prospère
durant cette période le désordre civil
règne dans toute la palestine en raison
des troubles croissants causés par les
extrémistes arabes sous le regard de la
police britannique
les arabes défilent pour protester
contre les juifs qui achètent la terre
et implante des villages
conséquence des émeutes
les maisons juives du quartier détruites
les magasins pillés et le sang versé
des renforts policiers sont appelés pour
rétablir l'ordre
les pompiers locaux viennent à la
rescousse mais souvent trop tard
les routes de palestine devienne
dangereuse à moins de circuler en convoi
les soldats britanniques assurent la
protection les voitures blindés de la
police ouvre la voie tandis que les
milices d implantation juive tente de
maintenir l'ordre durant les fréquentes
période de friction pour les
propriétaires féodaux arabe le mode de
vie juif est une menace contre le statu
quo les britanniques respectant leur
principe d' équilibre politique autorise
un groupe de juifs à s'enrôler dans les
forces de police de palestine c'est
ainsi cadeaux laissant de nombreux
officiers de l'armée israélienne ont
reçu leurs premières formations
militaires l'entraînement indispensable
pour limiter le nombre de morts causées
par les borgia
alors les juifs s'endurcissent
dans chaque implantation chaque secteur
isolé il s'initie aux techniques
militaires oublié depuis 2001 car depuis
les combattants de la liberté à massada
qui s'opposèrent aux romains jamais les
juifs en tant que peuple n'ont appris
l'art de la guerre dans les tours de
guet isoler les jeunes gens veillent sur
la paix
les gardes patrouillent aussi dans les
vergers guettant les maraudeurs
les britanniques entraîne aussi les
arabes
un groupe de dignitaires lors d'une
cérémonie du souvenir dans les années 50
golda meir institutrice et futur premier
ministre
mayer 10 nov maire de tel aviv ben
gourion moche et charrettes et prime
weizman qui deviendra le premier
président d'israël
le nouvel état juif a besoin de sa
propre culture et de sa propre langue
pour unir les juifs de l'orient et de
l'occident on ressuscite l'hébreu et on
l'adapté un usage moderne les caractères
antique apparaissent dans la presse et
dans la vie quotidienne de ceux qui
vivent en palestine une réalisations
monumentales à l'initiative d'eliezer
ben-yehuda considéré comme le père de
l'hébreu moderne
le rêve de la terre promise se réalise
de même que la prophétie d'ezéchiel sur
la vallée des ossements desséchés le
peuple juif renaît dans le désert il
laboure creuse le sol est rôdé de son
ancienne patrie
et tout cela grâce aux travaux
d'irrigation qui font verdoyer la terre
aride et rocailleuse
le blé qui pousse vers le ciel
ensoleillé
la majesté nous des oliviers les
troupeaux à l'est
l'eau régénérante qui fait pousser les
fruits dans le désert
tandis que les exportations agricoles se
développe l'industrie prospère les
vastes usines se dote de machinerie
massive que les travailleurs apprennent
à manoeuvrer
pendant ce temps les arabes continuent
de mener leurs existences frustre
inchangé depuis des générations
mais leur chef s'inquiète devant les
progrès et la productivité croissante
des sionistes qui contraste avec leur
propre système féodal
et aussi devant cette jeune génération
de juifs élevé d'une façon entièrement
différente avec de nouveaux objectifs et
vivent en plein air malheureusement les
actes terroristes permanent des voisins
arabes perturbé la vie
ailleurs au dessus de l'europe les
nuages se font menaçants
hitler redouté de ses opposants envahi
ses voisins sans peine détruisant tous
et infligeant aux juifs la plus grande
souffrance de leur histoire déjà
sanglante
ils sont raflés entassées comme du
bétail dans des camions à destination
des chambres à gaz
les ghettos sont fermés et incendiés
les lamentations de leurs habitants
résonne dans toute la planète mais peu
de secours leur sont envoyés quelques
uns résistent
mais en général les gens n'ont aucune
possibilité de fuir chacun s'accroche
désespérément à l'espoir que lui et sa
famille y trouveront un moyen de
survivre
dans chaque pays conquis les nazis
procède à une chasse méthodique aux
juifs
certains parviennent à y échapper grâce
à la chance ou à la compassion de leurs
amis chrétiens mais la plupart comme ses
enfants finissent leur vie dans les
camps de concentration
les allemands utilisent un gaz mortel et
le monde apprend un nouveau mot génocide
le totalitarisme et finalement vaincu
par les armées alliées victorieuse mais
l'ombre d'hitler s'attarde sur la totale
destruction qu'il a causé à son propre
pays et aux autres telle est la
contribution de la race supérieure à la
civilisation
pour beaucoup il n'y aura pas de retour
car depuis longtemps ils ont péri dans
les camps ou dans l'anéantissement du
ghetto de varsovie dont il ne reste
presque rien hormis cinq kilomètres
carrés de décombres là où vivait jadis
une communauté juive florissante
l'ampleur de la destruction dépasse
l'imagination
oh
les terribles secrets et des camps ne
seront totalement révélé qu'à l'entrée
des soldats alliés qui comprennent alors
l'énormité de ce crime contre l'humanité
le pitoyable rescapés sont transportés
avec précaution en des camps
seuls les jeunes parviennent à arborer
un courageux sourire
les masses d'apatrides parmi lesquels
des dizaines de milliers de juifs sont
aidés par divers organismes sociaux qui
tente de redonner forme à leur vie
brisée ils rentrent d'abord dans leurs
foyers
s'il n'est pas détruit et chez leurs
proches si par chance
ceux ci vivent encore beaucoup cependant
ne peuvent supporter de retourner sur
des lieux où ce qu'il chérissait sont
morts violemment
les home d'enfants sont établis en
europe occidentale pour soigner la
jeunesse juive et comme les enfants sont
malléables
c'est une tâche plus facile
tous les enfants savent oublié et on
peut les préparer une installation
définitive en palestine
appelez
on repart nutritifs et conseillers
affectueux les aides à effacer leurs
souvenirs de famine et de cruauté
beaucoup d'adultes apatrides participe à
un mouvement clandestin qui leur permet
de traverser illégalement diverses
frontière jusqu'à la terre promise
l'immigration est limitée par les
britanniques contrairement au terme du
mandat défini par la société des nations
ce mouvement clandestin le plus
important de l'histoire
dirigé par des juifs de palestine
assurera le transport de trois cent
mille personnes
parfois il voyage de nuit par convois de
camions jusqu'à des plages isolées où
ils s'embarquent pour leur traversée
secrète
bien que les juifs palestiniens se soit
distingué au cours de la guerre la
police britannique campe sur sa volonté
de maintenir un équilibre entre les
populations juives et arabes en terre
sainte
ils sont des milliers à monter ainsi à
bord de vieux cargo surchargé
il rêve de parvenir à briser le blocus
britannique et de commencer une nouvelle
existence en palestine
et
ils doivent supporter des conditions
difficiles mais l'espoir les fait tenir
des familles entières se pressent dans
des espaces réduits avec à peine la
place pour s'allonger
les gens sont entassés les uns sur les
autres sur des gradins sous le pont au
cas où un avion de reconnaissance
britannique survolerait le bateau celui
ci passerait alors pour un banal cargo
sans laisser deviner la masse humaine
qu'il transporte
car il faut échapper aux bâtiments de
guerre de la flotte britannique
si l'on veut rejoindre les plages
secrète de palestine
parfois les réfugiés peuvent prendre un
peu de liberté
ils sont habitués à des installations
sanitaires rudimentaire et à des
provisions de vivres très limité il
s'efforce de rester propre avec le peu
d'eau disponible
les mères espèrent que leurs enfants
grandiront dans un monde différent
les chefs de groupe s'assure que les
rations sont soigneusement distribués et
il règne un fort esprit de solidarité
même après tant de souffrances et de
morts l'étincelle la volonté de survivre
persiste
et pour les hommes pris au grand jour
avec leur talent est leur télé fine et
leurs livres de prières il prie le dieu
de jacob de les délivrer une fois de
plus de l'esclavagé de l'errance
des bébés naissent sur le bateau une vie
nouvelle pour remplacer tant de vies
éteinte
mais peu de bateaux rejoindront la terre
promise le but presque atteint ils
seront refoulés
un pilote a deviné la réalité de la
situation et très vite les passagers
aperçoivent un destroyer britannique à
l'horizon
soucieux de la sécurité des femmes et
des enfants les responsables décident de
ne pas résister il n'y a rien à faire
excepté remontée pour prendre une
bouffée d'air et patientez anxieusement
tandis que le vaisseau britannique
approche
le pavillon du bateau clandestin est
fièrement hissé
les voyageurs attendent l'escort en
silence leurs espoirs d'atteindre la
palestine briser leur futur incertain
une fois les marins britanniques à bord
le bateau obtient l'autorisation
d'entrer dans le port de haïfa mais les
passagers sont virtuellement prisonniers
leur séjour sera court juste le temps de
les faire monter sur des vaisseaux
prison à destination de l'île proche de
chypre
on les conduit le long de la passerelle
vers des enclos de fils barbelés
et on les débarque dans les camps de
détention à chypre
alex xs au siège de l'onu les orateurs
dénonce les uns après les autres ce
spectacle des juifs une fois de plus
emprisonnés pour des raisons politiques
alors en novembre 1947 les nations unies
décide d'un plan de partage de la
palestine en deux états un juif et un
arabe avec la condition que les
britanniques aient quitté le pays pour
le 15 mai 1948
et à la date fixée les britanniques par
effectivement du port de haïfa
rapatriant leurs soldats heureux de
retourner dans leurs familles et enfin
libéré de ce rôle fin ce qu'ils ont dû
jouer dans la destinée des juifs
dans un petit amphithéâtre du musée de
tel-aviv david ben gourion chef du
conseil provisoire proclame la naissance
de l'état d'israël
le roi abdallah de jordanie commandant
en chef des forces arabes alliés donne
l'ordre d'envahir immédiatement israël
au même moment l'armée clandestine juive
la haganah utilisant le matériel dont
elle dispose
sort grand jour pour défendre le nouvel
état
la population reste calme face aux raids
aériens que les arabes lancent contre
les villes juives
avec des armes dépasser les juifs
combattent les bombardiers et
parviennent à les chasser
mais non sans perte
le temps vaillamment avec un armement
réduit contre les avions et les chars du
monde arabe
les israéliens se battent dans les
implantations et les villages de tout le
pays
jerusalem l'artillerie arabe tirent sur
la population civile
comme toujours les juifs sauf d'abord
les rouleaux de la loi
beaucoup regard de leur maison détruite
par les obus de la légion arabe entraîné
et commandé par des britanniques
malgré les embuscades des convois
israélien acheminer des vivres vers
jérusalem a siégé la population juive
unis se bat contre l'énorme appareil
militaire de l'ensemble du monde arabe
les colons des régions rurales sont
coupés de tout secours
ouais
prat poussant les attaques sporadiques
ils voient leurs récoltes incendié par
des maraudeurs arabe
les enfants les premiers à souffrir en
temps de guerre sont évacués dans des
voitures blindées artisanale les adultes
reste et continue de travailler la terre
du mieux qu'ils peuvent toujours prêt à
prendre les armes sur le champ pour se
défendre
ils n'ont pas d'alternative et c'est une
arme en soit ils sont déterminés à ne
pas se laisser décimée comme tant de
millions de leurs frères en europe s'ils
doivent mourir
ce sera en luttant pour leur droit à la
vie
m
le dos à la mer les israéliens voient le
labeur de tant d'années leur culture
leurs projets de construction réduit en
ruines mais ils continuent de lutter car
ils n'ont pas d'autre choix
là où des oiseaux chantaient on trouve
maintenant des monceaux de terre
fraîchement retournée
l'ennemi perd aussi beaucoup d'hommes
dans ce carnage absurde et finalement
les états arabes acceptent un armistice
avec l'aide des nations unies le dernier
de toute une série est signée en 1949
le président weizman reçoit les premiers
ambassadeurs des états unis et de la
russie
les juifs capturé au combat rentrer en
israël
et on célèbre la victoire
les soldats de tout le pays se
rassemblent dans la ville de tibériade
pour défiler devant le nouveau premier
ministre david ben gourion les quelques
avions que les forces israéliennes
possède à présent survole les troupes
disparates mais victorieuse qui défilent
dignement devant les chefs
le nouvel état
non
la dernière demeure de jeunes israéliens
qui ont donné leur vie pour celle de
leur nation
à
les décombres sont dégagés les artisans
retournent à leur paisible activités
rebâtissant ce qui a été détruit
reprenant le fil de la vie normale la
première tâche est de reconstruire et
d'aller toujours de l'avant dans un pays
libre et indépendant
un pays de paix avec de grandes
perspectives d'avenir
aux nations unies 1 x est organisée
ces charrettes accepte au nom de l'état
d'israël
détails
et comme avant durant tant d'années
les travaux de construction reprenne
avec vigueur et résolution le dynamisme
du pays se ressent partout des rêves se
réalisent après un millénaire
d'oppression et de lutte permanente pour
la survie
et
où
des milliers de familles érigent des
maisons et les fragiles abris de toile
se transforme enfin en solide
habitations le pierre et de ciment mais
les israéliens ne sont pas sortis des
tranchées et n'en sortiront pas avant
longtemps
tout en creusant les fossés d'irrigation
et en installant les canalisations d'eau
il demeure en alerte
souvent après une dure journée de labeur
un homme part pour la nuit
faire son tour de garde en disant au
revoir à sa famille sans savoir si la
reverra le lendemain car il ya de
nombreuses attaques des fedayins les
escadrons terroriste égyptiens qui
s'aventurent à travers la frontière et
la police locale s'efforce de gérer les
conséquences tragiques que ces
envahisseurs laissent derrière eux ces
événements exaspère la population qui
après huit années de harcèlement et de
crimes exige la cessation du terrorisme
et le droit de vivre en paix
et
en octobre 1956 l'armée israélienne à
présent équipés d'armements modernes
entre dans le sinaï pour contrer une
armée égyptienne massive détruire les
bases de ravitaillement dirigé par les
terroristes et briser le blocus illégal
du détroit de tiran les parachutistes
israéliens lâcher des avions de
transport atterrissent à l'arrière des
lignes ennemies dans le désert
l'infanterie combats les forces arabes
toujours supérieure en nombre et en
armement mais pas en qualité humaine
les routes du sinaï sont jonchées de
blindés russes détruits
un flot ininterrompu de prisonniers
arabes un arsenal soviétique suffisant
pour équiper une armée sur des années
saisi par les forces israéliennes au
cours de la campagne
pourtant bien que les victoires étaient
difficiles israël accepte en 1957 de se
retirer de la péninsule du sinaï en
échange de garanties internationales
la paix revient et la vie reprend son
cours normal
un autre commencement davantage de
bâtiments construits les ressources en
eau a exploité la poursuite de la
conquête du désert le développement de
grands projets d'irrigation durant dix
ans israël va jouir d'une paix relative
jusqu'au printemps 1967 lorsque se
profile une nouvelle menace de guerre
les terroristes reprennent leurs actions
meurtrières
les accords d'armistice n'ont pas de
sens pour ces jeunes dont la maison
communautaire a été détruite
c'est comme la résurgence d'un ancien
cauchemar les incidents se multiplient
le monde arabe continue ses provocations
ces chefs se réunissent et projette une
nouvelle guerre pour détruire israël
dans les capitales arabes les soldats
défilent pas très joliment mais bien
déterminé à rejeter les israéliens à la
mer pendant qu'à tel aviv
les foules se rassemblent lors de
manifestations silencieuses pour exiger
la réouverture du détroit international
de tirana de nouveau il également
bloquée par les forces égyptiennes en
vain des israéliens attendent que les
engagements internationaux pris dix ans
auparavant soit honorée
et
de nombreux diplomates elles abba eban
sont reçus dans les capitales du monde
mais sans rien d'obtenir les nations
unies sur un simple ordre de nasser
retirent leurs forces de maintien de la
paix avec elle disparaît la dernière
lueur d'espoir d'une vie paisible
les chefs israéliens se réunit
solennellement à huis clos pour
déterminer le destin de leur peuple
l'entraînement de défense civile est
rigoureusement pratiquer comme dans
toutes les périodes de tension des 20
dernières années
israël se prépare au pire
la nuit ont rempli des sacs de sable les
hommes femmes et enfants se mettent au
travail ensemble faisant leur possible
pour se préparer à neutraliser une fois
de plus une tentative général arabe pour
détruire l'état d'israël
cette fois le sang n'est pas absurdement
versées mais donner volontairement
partout la tension se lit sur les
visages
l'armée israélienne est confiante même
s'il il faut affronter des masses de
soldats ennemis et 900 avions prêts à
l'attaqué
les mystères aile delta de fabrication
française piloté par les israéliens
d'école pour contrer les migs égyptien
avec des résultats spectaculaires
une preuve s'il en fallait il faut plus
que des mig pour faire la puissance
d'une nation
les tanks et les abstracts entre en
action les soldats sont déterminés à ce
que le peuple juif continue de vivre
les avions légers de reconnaissance
localise les cibles pour les canaux
mobiles autopropulsés
les fumées noires à l'horizon atteste de
la précision des tireurs israéliens
dans le sinaï les forces blindées de
l'armée égyptienne jadis si fier sont
réduites à l'état de carcasse comme en
1956 les israéliens avant sans répit le
long du vaste front sud à coude à son
incessant de jour comme de nuit
ne s'arrêtant que pour rendre hommage à
leur commandant suprême avec la forte
conviction biblique que la main du tout
puissant a confondu l'ennemi
il pénètre dans la ville côtière arabes
de gaza
les derniers combattants de
l'orgueilleux armées ennemies sont à
présent prisonniers
l'effort se motoriser israélienne entre
en action pour neutraliser les quelques
points d'appui restants
le soldat en jeep utilisent des
mitrailleuses automatiques pour effacer
les dernières traces résistance arabe
et toujours le mot d'ordre en avant cris
de bataille de l'armée israélienne
jusqu à al-arich ancien aéroport clés de
la force aérienne égyptiennes dans le
sinaï
davantage de prisonniers
un général de division est interrogé par
les agents du renseignement israélien
et
le visage des captifs exprime tension
est ahuri semant la plupart ne
connaissent même pas le nom de leur chef
les soldats arabes essentiellement de la
classe paysanne ne peuvent pas courir
avec leurs chaussures
le prix élevé de la victoire payer en
sang israélien des soldats célèbrent
leur triomphe
plus avant vers la zone du canal de suez
les vestiges encore en flammes de la
puissante armée égyptienne équipés par
les russes
ouais
puis les trois bandes du canal paisible
et déserté le pont d'ismaïlia détruits
par les égyptiens en fuite
craignant d'être poursuivies de l'autre
côté les chefs israéliens s'arrête pour
évaluer la situation
leur ordre sont de ne pas aller plus
loin
les soldats prennent un repos bien
mérité et profite de la première rhône
ont rationné pour se rafraîchir
près du canal le général itshak rabin
chef d'état major israélien visitent le
site de missiles soviétiques pointés
vers le coeur d'israël
le général rabin inspectent aussi les la
camair ce des bateaux ils sont échoués
en raison du blocus égyptien sur le
canal de suez les canons du détroit de
tirana présent détruits sont réduits au
silence
les israéliens débarque à
charm-el-cheikh sans obstacle
les patrouilleurs israéliens contrôlent
désormais l'est voie maritime jusqu'au
port d'eilat au sud sur la mer rouge
pendant ce temps les bombardiers
israéliens attaquent les fortifications
syrienne sur les hauteurs du golan dont
les canons pilonnent les villages du
nord d'israël depuis 20 ans
les israéliens avancent avec leurs tanks
et leur bulldozer ouvrant leur propre
route sur ce terrain escarpé
les combattants israéliens parviennent à
avancer sur ces pentes abruptes
contre toute attente
des prisonniers syrien encore stupéfait
de l'assaut qu'ils ont subis des
hauteurs du golan la valley israélienne
dulas présent paisible connaîtra
deuxième ville de syrie que les unités
de première ligne israélienne trouve
déserté
les blessés légers israéliens sera mené
en bateau par la mer de galilée
non
les plus atteints sont évacués par
hélicoptère et conduits dans des
hôpitaux et sur les tables d'opération
15 ou 20 minutes après être tombé ce qui
explique le nombre relativement limité
de mort
pour eux la guerre s'est terminée avant
que le cessez-le-feu n'entre en vigueur
jerusalem bombardée par les jordaniens
alors que les israéliens avaient supplié
le jeune roi hussein de rester en dehors
des combats
le pilonnage aveugle des canons
jordanien cause de multiples victimes et
incendie
et toujours des chaussures abandonnées
et des prisonniers
jérusalem est à l'issue de durs combats
les forces israéliennes ont écrasé la
légion jordanienne et réunifier la ville
les réfugiés civils rentrer chez eux des
enfants perdus sont rendus à leurs
familles
au mur des lamentations un grand moment
moshe dayan ministre de la défense
israélien apparaît devant le vestige
historique du temple les soldats ému
partage ce sentiment de proximité et
d'attachement envers ses 3000 ans
d'histoire juive qui les ont précédés et
qui se dressent symboliquement devant te
sous la forme d'un mur qu'ils peuvent
toucher contre lequel ils peuvent
pleurer et prier
des hommes et femmes de tous âges des
barbes blanches et des visages rasé de
près des armes à portée de main et des
livres de prières ouvert
quelques jours plus tard la fête de
shavouot commémorant le don de la torah
donne lieu à une grande célébration
les juifs retourne sur la tombe des
patriarches
comme le veut la tradition des morceaux
de papier contenant des voeux sont
glissés entre les pierres les hassidim
dans soigneusement sur la tombe d'abrams
la liberté pour toutes les religions
les gens peuvent prier comme il le
désire
jerusalem de nouveau en paix les cloches
sonnent l'heure des messes chrétienne
le moisi n'appelle les fidèles d'allah
dans tout le pays encore des prières
pour qu'enfin le conflit et le sang
versé prenne fin mais l'expérience amère
des israéliens lors a appris que le
meilleur espoir de paix repose dans une
préparation permanente et l'armée est
prête à affronter toute menace contre le
pays au cours de son histoire le peuple
juif s'est battu contre tout espoir pour
le droit à exister
un monument en hommage à ceux qui sont
tombés et ont fait le sacrifice suprême
je vais
une terre de promesses et de réalisation
un pays de croissance et de prospérité
des vergers poussant sur des terres
arides des maisons érigées dans le
désert et des fermiers se vend des
graines qui pousseront pour être
récoltées par les générations à venir
j'apporterai la paix sur cette terre et
personne ne vous effraie ras des hommes
et des femmes avec des numéros tatoué
sur le bras ou d'origine arabe
travaillant à présent en citoyen libre
dans l'état d'israël
les écoles arabes enseignants le coran
et la langue de leurs peuples
tandis que la minorité arabe poursuit sa
propre recherche culturelle dans une
société pluraliste jeunes et vieux
immigrants et autochtones d'origines
différentes vivent ensemble pour une
démocratie dynamique s'efforçant de
construire un avenir sûr et paisible
israël une terre chérie né d'un rêve
taillés à la main dans la pierre
biblique baigner du sang des martyrs
maintenu par la fois un miracle de
survie
pour ce rallye
les